it's a show that at first stunned and
then galvanized the country a live
political debate unscripted and unedited
at first in Uzbekistan there have been
29 others over the past three months
we're wide range of topics were
discussed often putting the candidates
on the spot to the point that this party
leader admitted who's back politicians
lack courage we didn't anticipate this
level of success it was difficult at
first because politicians weren't ready
for this but then they prepared and were
able to answer questions they didn't
expect people have become more
interested in the parties and their
programs the New York combative is a
proud cook of Uzbekistan national dish
cloth and despite stirring hundreds of
kilos of rice a day he followed the
debates you're parsing us there was a
lot of truth and real issues with these
debates we can understand what needs to
be done in the correct way and what is
wrong there is a lot of change and these
elections are very different from
previous ones whose backs will have to
choose between five parties ranging from
left to right under political spectrum
but all our government funded with
similar platforms there are no
opposition or independent candidates
running in this election but who's Becky
stan is only 28 years old it was formed
after the fall of the Soviet Union in
1991 so regardless of the shortcomings
people are excited to go to the ballot
boxes still for the first time the
parties are somehow competing against
each other to win over voters since
President Jeff cat Mears EOF took power
in 2016 he is gradually taking the
country out of isolation reforms in
almost all spheres of our life social
life political life economic life in
some spheres we see great success in
some spheres we see some controversial
changes and some spheres we see real
problems of
he has permitted greater freedom of
expression which allows Kamala Dean is a
cool-off to speak to us without fear of
repercussion at 31 he's a first-time
voter he supports the Liberal Democratic
Party because it promised to back small
businesses like his previous elections
we are just nominally now we say freely
what we think before we were scared we
can see the reality even if it's still
not completely transparent I hope this
will continue and it will become more
liberal president Mears EOF promised
that Parliament will become a true
school of democracy millions of Jews
Beck's hope that day comes sooner rather
than later
but after Hamad Al Jazeera Tashkent in
Uzbekistan